first of all congratulations gold medal
what does that feel like thank you -
it's incredible you know just it really
didn't hit me until we got on the medal
stand and you know obviously you see the
third-place team get theirs in the
second-place team and then all of a
sudden they're naming us offering then
our flags raised and they're playing our
national anthem like it was an
incredible feeling I really had the
chills that's so nice that's I mean
that's a that's a thing that people
dream about where do you keep your medal
now do you wear it or I mean if I have
one of those things I would wear it
everywhere so I'd wear it to the clubs
I'd wear it everywhere well Katie had
his own at the Monday Night Football
game last night and we still have our
group chatting we all talked about him I
do give it a break it looks a little
desperate like what are you doing yeah
everybody know you wanted Katie give it
a break yeah yeah no I miss Dumars who's
a mother to me the wife of Joe Dumars
she keeps my so it's finger heads I got
a question for you you play in this
Olympic team and you're playing with
guys from all different teams okay your
teammates with them but now the seasons
starting up you gotta get into the head
of competing against these guys who were
your teammates is that tough it's not
tough you know the thing that I'm
excited about like a lot of fans like I
actually got a pretty close with Kyrie
and yellow and you know DeMarcus like
our entire team was super tight and a
lot of people if they knew that we still
text today and our group chat every day
they'd be mad like all you guys supposed
to hate each other
and I feel the complete opposite about
it like if I'm friends with you I want
to be true from worse than I did we
weren't friends so gives you a bigger
edge because you've gotten to know them
you've been friends and now you really
want to beat them absolutely because
we're going to talk junk out there we're
probably going to go to dinner after the
game and dinner will be a lot better if
I can tell you that dinner's on you
because I beat you
how do how to NBA kind of NBA stores
when they get dinner together how do
they figure out who's paying so on our
team on our Warriors team yet we play
credit card roulette sorry [ __ ] relax so
we everybody take their car they put it
in the Hat and the server whoever was
the server they pull cars up the last
card in you pay it's it's rough
sometimes cuz I imagine you know you
guys are eating ordering with some nice
meals right you ordered some sides
you're getting some big bottles of wine
absolutely and that's the thing you know
the bottles of wine can put it up there
no obviously Festus Ezeli is no longer
with us he's obviously still our brother
forever but he didn't pass away that
sounded bad
when when they came the credit card
roulette you wanted to see Festus loose
yeah because he was bad like he sweat
like he had like it was real he acted
like he was in Oh I mean give it a break
you